my name is matt and you're watching my
channel
about code and technology and stuff
and i wanted to talk today about a
little subject game engines
and why you should have your own i think
pretty much every programmer anybody
who's studying computer science
especially anyone that's going into the
game development realm should be working
on their
own game engine and the probably the
biggest
argument against this is well there's
already so many
what am i really going to contribute and
that that is a counter-intuitive
argument because
if you want to contribute ever you have
to get some practice you can do that on
your own because coding is free you just
need the knowledge
and if you're studying it it is such a
great way to start honing
your skills and learning so much more
about
how things are structured how game
engines work all the
basically all the underlying work that
goes into it so i've been working on
this
engine of my own called ancient archer
for quite a while now
this is a game engine i started several
years ago it sort of started
back when i was taking a graphics
programming class and i was trying to
figure out how to make
a game basically and just kind of
getting some things in there
to handle it and we were not allowed to
use a game engine for this class because
we were learning from the ground up if
you want to program
games sure you can just jump into a game
engine and follow tutorials and whatnot
but it's going to take you a really long
time to kind of get the core knowledge
and understand
where all those bass stuff comes from
because it's going to seem like
some kind of some kind of magical black
box
but once you actually start diving into
an engine and
making your own you start to see oh this
is how this works
so let me talk a bit about this engine
and what's changed since the last vlog
since the last vlog well it's been a
while i think the last vlog i had some
really ambitious targets i said stuff
like
i want to get animations working i want
to get all the textures working i want
to get some pbr
lighting and i had like a whole bunch of
really big things that would have taken
a whole team of people months to do and
it just wasn't realistic and the more i
thought about it
the more i realized that so i've just
started to pick little things here and
there and just incrementally improve it
so what i've done since the last vlog
well this is now a library
so you can get the whole engine as just
a library and use it on
a project and that really simplifies the
structure because before it was like
it was all just one program it was just
an application and you would have to add
like
a main to run and it was weird it was
very weird but since i've been learning
a lot about libraries
i finally took the time to to basically
turn this into a library so if you look
at this main a
engine it is just a static library i
could do it as a dynamic one as well
but that way i could actually ship the
binaries to somebody
without all the code well i guess they'd
need the headers and they could just use
it without worrying about the behind the
scenes code
so that is a pretty cool thing and as i
go on and work on it
i'm basically just i just keep adding
things which i've got a few demos just
to test that everything was working
so now that my engine is set up as a
library i can basically make
executable projects or just side
projects and just link it so here i've
got
a another project i just named classic
asteroids where i'm going to try
and recreate classic asteroids with my
engine because if i can get all that to
work
that'll be stuff i can test my engine
with and kind of know what i need to do
next
so let's check out what this asteroid
looks like and i'll show you uh just
real quick
a little about it so i made all these
models with blender and textured and
blender and just loaded them up with my
engine as you can see i got some some
asteroids that actually spin randomly
and i got all the movements sorted out
which uses rotation
and just some simple math to tell what
direction you're going in so that you
can move forward
and i made just a little object to fire
and currently i'm working on all the
colliding stuff and learning about that
i've been studying a lot on that
i kind of had some basic versions of it
in but it's not really good enough to
use in the long run so i've got to make
some more improvements
if you have any good recommendations for
physics libraries that are
like really lightweight i might add them
i thought about adding bullet physics
but
it's a bit of a heavy library i might
still do it at some point if i really
stay stuck
on this too long but once i get some
colliders figured out i'm going to make
this bullet explode these and they'll
shatter into smaller ones and all that's
particle effects and all that cool stuff
but for now i just got the ship flying
around i've got a couple of these
spawning as a demo i could arbitrarily
spawn any of
as many as i want and move them around
but they currently don't collide until i
get that collider stuff sorted
out so once again this is a great thing
as i study all this
collider stuff this is this is like a
perfect place for me to test it
where i don't have to be judged by a
boss or a code review
person at work or something so even if
you work on a game engine or on a game
at work
you still might as well have your own
game engine to work on so that you can
test things initially
in a place that's uh you know just
basically totally open and free since
it's totally up to you
it's done in 168 lines of code including
all the brackets and includes and stuff
so it's actually not
all that much code to get all of that
right there working
and i can just keep adding to it as i
figure out new stuff i think i've got
all the stuff i declare i load the all
the models required and it's just a few
lines to load the models
pretty simple to do once you have this
engine included
and then i've got some functions i add
to the update for handling the keys
and for controlling the ship and for
firing the bullet
and if anything is ever off i can always
just go analyze this and adjust as
needed
like at some point i'll probably do
tetris and i'll make snake and
i'll just keep going on and on and make
a bunch of simple games is basically the
plan
at first i was making like complicated
3d games where
i was like first person which actually
worked half decently
but as i made them i realized
i began to realize how much stuff the
engine was missing because i had to
basically put
program a bunch of stuff in the
executable like a long time ago i did a
demo where it was sort of like minecraft
and i could interact with blocks
but all that block stuff was all in this
application code
and it should be in the engine right so
that's basically what i learned but i
sort of figured it out in the
application code but now i'm moving it
into the engine
so there's a lot of stuff like that it's
just a great learning experience you
should definitely have your own game
engine that's the whole point of this
video and to show you the update
about where this ancient archer vlog is
i'll catch you guys in the next video
peace out
[Music]
you